"THE FIVE" ."
A NEW POLL SHOWS 53% OF
AMERICANS SAY TALKING POLITICS
WITH SOMEONE THEY DISAGREE WITH
IS STRESSFUL AND FRUSTRATING.
THIS IS SURPRISING.
IT MEANS OUR 47% WHO DON'T FIND
TALKING POLITICS WITH SOMEONE
THEY DISAGREE WITH TO BE
STRESSFUL AND FRUSTRATING.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
AROUND THAT TIME I USUALLY DO A
MONOLOGUE AND HOW TO REDUCE
POLITICAL TENSION AT
THANKSGIVING DINNER.
IT NEVER HELPS.
NO ONE EVER LISTENS.
WHY SHOULD THEY?
TAKING ADVICE FROM A TV HOST IS
LIKE TAKING A RIDE FROM A
STRANGER.
IT'S RISKY AND YOU OFTEN END UP
DEAD.
SO INSTEAD OF ABORTING POLITICS,
LET'S GO ALL IN AT THANKSGIVING.
FIRST WE MUST FIND THE RIGHT WAY
TO INSERT IT INTO DINNER
CONVERSATION.
HERE ARE SOME EXAMPLES.
THESE MASHED POTATOES ARE REALLY
HOT.
ALMOST AS HOT AS OUR ECONOMY
WHICH UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP GREW
AT A THREE TO 4% RATE.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE MORE GENERALS
THAN PEOPLE, MUCH LIKE JOBS
UNDER DONALD TRUMP UPGRADE
4 MILLION OF THEM IN YEARS.
SO WHY DON'T YOU CARVE THE
TURKEY, JUST LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CARVED OUR
BLOATED BUREAUCRACY WHEN HE CUT
16 RULES AND REGULATIONS FOR
EVERYONE CREATED.
LOOKS LIKE WE RAN OUT OF GRAVY.
MUCH LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO OUR
DOCTORS UNDER OBAMACARE.
THANK GOD DONALD TRUMP REVEALED
THAT MANDATE.
AM I RIGHT, GRANDMA?
I AM STOPPED, MUCH LIKE THE
SUPREME COURT IS WITH TWO
STERLING APPOINTMENTS.
MAY BE THAT KIDS CAN CLEAR THE
TABLE JUST LIKE TRUMP CLEARED
THE COUNTRY OF MS-13.
JAIME, CAN YOU TAKE OUT THE
TRASH?
PUT IT ON THE CURB NEXT TO THE
PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD AND THE
AWFUL IRAN TREATY.
I LOVE PUMPKIN PIE.
DOESN'T THE COLOR REMIND YOU OF
DONALD TRUMP'S GORGEOUS HAIR?
IF YOU CAN'T AVOID POLITICS, WHY
AVOID POLITICS?
INSTEAD SET THE TONE IN THE
TABLE WITH THE TRUTH BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T, SOMEONE ELSE SURELY
WILL.
I'M GOING TO GO TO THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE CONFLICTING THANKS
GIVING TABLES.
JESSE, DO YOUR PARENTS GO HARD
ON YOU FOR BEING AN UNPAID
SPOKESMAN FOR DONALD TRUMP?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: VERY FUNNY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A REALLY GOOD
MONOLOGUE, ONE OF YOUR BETTER
ONES.
[LAUGHTER]
I WASN'T BEING SARCASTIC.
I THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY GOOD.
THE KEY TO SURVIVING MY
THANKSGIVING IS RESPECTING YOUR
ELDERS BECAUSE DURING THE BUSH
YEARS, I GOT A LITTLE COCKY.
STOCKS WERE UP.
THE SURGE WORKED.
MY PARENTS ARE LIBERALS AND MY
GRANDFATHER IS A COMMUNIST.
WE ARE AROUND THE DINNER TABLE
IN 2006 OR '07 AND I STARTED
QUOTING RUSH LIMBAUGH.
GRANDFATHER SLAMS HIS FIST ON
THE TABLE AND SAYS "YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE HELL YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT!"
THE WHOLE TABLE WENT QUIET.
THEN HE FORGOT HE WAS ANGRY.
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW, JESSE,
PAST THE PUMPKIN CHEESECAKE.
THAT'S WHAT'S GREAT ABOUT OLD
PEOPLE.
THEY FORGET WHY THEY ARE ANGRY.
SOMETIMES IT'S GOOD TO KNOW
WHICH THEY ARE NOT TO POKE.
>> Greg: IS HE STILL WITH US?
>> Jesse: GOD REST HIS SOUL.
>> Greg: I WAS WONDERING IF HE
WAS WATCHING.
>> Jesse: IF HE WAS STILL
HERE, HE WOULD NOT BE WATCHING
"THE FIVE."
>> Greg: YOU HAVE A COMMUNIST
GRANDDAD.
JUAN, YOU ARE THE FATHER TO TWO
REPUBLICANS AND ONE LIBERAL.
>> Juan: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Greg: AT CHRISTMAS, DOES
THE LIBERAL GET BETTER GIFTS?
>> Juan: THE LIBERAL AS MY
DAUGHTER.
I GIVE THEM ALL GREAT GIFTS.
>> Greg: DO YOU EVER END UP ON
TEAMS AROUND THE DINNER TABLE
WITH YOUR SONS AND YOU AND YOUR
DAUGHTER TEAMING UP AGAINST THEM
POLITICALLY?
>> Juan: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU MISSED IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE WAS A LOT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY AGREE ON THINGS, EVEN
IF THEY ARE LIBERAL OR
CONSERVATIVE.
THERE'S A LOT THEY AGREE ON.
>> Jesse: LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: NO, HOW ABOUT NOT
INSULTING THE GUY WHO TOOK OUT
BIN LADEN.
YOU KNOW, HOW ABOUT --
>> Greg: HE HAD IT COMING.
>> Juan: WHAT DID TRUMP SAY?
HE WAS A CLINTON SUPPORTER.
HOW ABOUT NOT SAYING THAT YOU
ARE CIA -- LET'S IGNORE THEM.
WE HAVE SOMETHING BETTER.
WE DON'T AGREE WITH YOUR
CONCLUSION.
>> Greg: THESE ARE LIBERAL
TALKING POINTS.
>> Juan: THAT'S RIGHT.
MAYBE YOU COULD SAY A DINNER
TABLE WITH TRUMP AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND KIM JONG IL.
YOU CAN SAY I BELIEVE EVERYTHING
THEY SAY.
IT'S GOOD WITH ME.
WHATEVER YOU SAY, JUST PAST THE
TURKEY.
>> Kennedy: I THINK IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE NOT STOCK BUT
POLITICS.
I THINK EVERYONE WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT POLITICS.
THE DIFFERENCE ON THANKSGIVING
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE HOSTING,
YOU HAVE TO SET THE RULES AND
YOU HAVE TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
DON'T TAKE THINGS PERSONALLY.
IT'S OKAY IF WE DISAGREE AND YOU
CAN HAVE A COMPETITION AND YOU
CAN EVEN KEEP SCORE.
YOU CAN HAVE A YELLOW PAD AND A
TALLY WITH COLUMNS AND
HASH MARKS AND WHOEVER GETS THE
BEST BARBS IN CATS THE BIGGEST
PIECE OF PIE.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
AT ALL BUT YOU HAVE TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW NOT TO TAKE IT
PERSONALLY.
WHEN SOMEONE SAYS SOMETHING YOU
DISAGREE, DON'T REACT LIKE IT'S
A PERSONAL SLIGHT.
WE HAVE TO DISTANCE OURSELVES
FROM POLITICS.
IT'S NOT THE ONLY THING THAT
DEFINES US IN POLITICS AS WELL
KNOW TALKING ABOUT IT, IT CAN BE
VERY PASSIONATE BUT IT COULD
ALSO BE SO MUCH FUN.
>> Greg: DANA, NO ONE TALKS
POLITICS AT YOUR PLACE BECAUSE
YOU'RE TOO BUSY TELLING THEM
ABOUT JASPER.
>> Dana: DOGS OF THE GREAT
EQUALIZER.
YOU CAN ALWAYS FIND COMMON
GROUND OF PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT
YOUR PETS AND YOUR LOVE OF PETS.
IF THINGS GET REALLY BAD AND YOU
HAVE THAT UNCOMFORTABLE SILENCE,
YOU CAN BRING UP A DOG.
I AM VERY SKILLED AT MAKING SURE
EVERYONE REALIZES WE ALL AGREE.
>> Kennedy: YOU AND JUAN ARE
SAYING THE SAME THING.
ONE YEAR I HAD AN EXPERIMENT.
I WANTED TO BRING UP THE MOST
UNCOMFORTABLE TOPICS THAT I
POSSIBLY COULD AND AT THAT TIME,
THE TWO WINNERS, BECAUSE IT WAS
2003, O.J. SIMPSON AND MY
GRANDMOTHER WAS VERY UPSET
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE -- IT
WAS A VERY HEATED CONVERSATION.
THIS WAS BEFORE THE BIG
DOCUMENTARY.
THE OTHER WAS WHAT DO YOU WANT
YOUR FUNERAL TO BE LIKE?
>> Greg: THAT'S NICE.
THAT MAKES POLITICS ACTUALLY --
YOU FOUND SOMETHING PEOPLE CAN
REVERT BACK.
>> Dana: YOU CAN ASK THE BULL
IT WAS THEIR BEST VACATION OF
THE YEAR AND YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
TRAVEL.
THERE'S THINGS TO TALK ABOUT.
>> Juan: WHAT IF I WAS JESSE'S
GRANDFATHER AND I SAID THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE, THEY ARE SO
IDIOTIC.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING.
LET'S FORGET ABOUT IT.
WE WILL GO TO JESSE.
>> Greg: MY SOLUTION: DRINK A